lol excuse me my voice is cracked no
screaming excuse me
he's screaming you know there's two
kinds of people in this world or it's
debatable
my name is Keith haha I'm Steven lol I
am team haha because I'm not a liar I'm
Kelsey and I l-o-l I'm on Team haha
because lol's four children and I laugh
out loud lol is the coolest hippest form
of communication there is on the
Internet Nick you're a cool guy what can
I say oh jeez I don't know was the og of
laughing language and I'm still using
I'm not ashamed to say I think I'm still
pretty cool would you say so
I think you're DS haha is a form of
speaking for older generation people how
old are you Keith I'm 28 we are now in
this new frontier where we are exploring
a whole new way of communicating or
getting lazier about the way we
communicate
therefore distancing ourselves from each
other now you just sound like an old man
says the old man you're around before
computers existed you're around when the
dinosaurs were here this is like this is
like arguing with a kindergartner
kindergartners are him there is one
thing that clinches lol over hahaha
which is that one-handed action is
capable on the keyboard oh oh are right
next to each other on the keyboard it's
more about that I believe that we should
be adding new words to our vocabulary
it's an acronym that's not adding a new
word to our vocabulary parties we've
been doing this for generations radar is
a word okay well it isn't it is also
inspired in many variations haha you
just have ha ha
ji Heon that's it what do you want to
emphasize something you say well oh oh
it's not a variation goes to words lol I
love
you can LMB oh you can ello ello ello
ello ello ello ha ha is the perfect
thing to text ha ha is so versatile you
can say ha ha you can just say ha you
could type ha ha ha you could be really
amused by this you could be pop space ha
and that's a sarcastic laugh oh yeah
you're liking a sword duel with someone
you go ha ha it means you have the upper
hand
yeah you said snootiest [ __ ] you would
say things like ha ha
which is older than LOL is too old the
original is the beginning steven the
beginning of technology the new age and
you are my friend a man of the dinosaurs
ha ha has been around since forever
forever beats 1998 over here everytime
10 times at a time LOL is if you're
right it is of technology and it only
belongs there
whereas haha can exist in text and in
life this is ha ha that's how you spell
it that sound just like you ng 8 haha
can be translated to any language based
on the way it sounds when people from
those cultures laugh LOL only works for
English speakers in Spanish ja ja which
is very close LOL is used to defuse
awkward situations hey you trying to
grab some drinks tonight LOL what is
funny why is that that's not i'm not
laughing out loud when i'm saying that
hey do you mind doing the dishes later
LOL what's funny about doing the dishes
that just means your roommates suck if
anything LOL yes is an iteration of haha
because it is saying ha don't hover over
see you're pretentious you like what
they do no literally appear like
this is what they do they trade spaces
that's how texts work Stephen
haha is what's appropriate
lol is too aggressive no one actually
means it and haha is just like huh you
tried good job
lol is universal it can apply to any
situation really listen I just think LOL
is for [ __ ] children and I only want
to talk to adults we can agree on one
thing anybody who says lol out loud they
are [ __ ] peanuts Psychopaths yeah no
way
you're old I'm cool go kindergarteners
we're done we out said it best the face
of defeat
as long as you've written down hey this
man this man is a train wreck